autre mesure de sobriété énergétique
cette fois a tout regardé cette carte à
partir de cette nuit trois quartiers
vont être plongés dans le noir les
Douets blanquis et faible vote plus
d'éclairage public donc entre 1h et 5
heures du matin l'opération va durer 6
mois alors qu'en pense les habitants
voyez ce reportage de Romainville
trois quartiers 44 rue de la ville de
Tours sont concernés par l'extinction
des lampadaires de 1h à 5h du matin
quartier faible vote ce sont quatre rues
entre les chemins de fer et les jardins
partagés Saint-Lazare
vraiment qui éclaire une partie de ma
cour qui soit éparguré
ici ça peut faire gagner ce sera
toujours ça voilà autre son de cloche
dans le quartier des Douets certes
l'espace boisé et les animaux qui vivent
seront tranquilles la nuit mais cet
habitant n'est pas rassurée à l'idée
d'un quartier dans le noir c'est vrai
que ici si c'est sombre qu'on voit plus
rien ça va être problématique parce
qu'avec tout ce qui se passe ces
derniers temps qu'on si on veut se faire
agresser dans le noir ou n'importe quoi
mais c'est vrai moi par exemple le matin
je travaille le travail quand je prends
le loup c'est vrai qu'il fait déjà noir
à 5h du matin par exemple ça me fait un
peu peur passe mon temps à me regarder
derrière moi s'il y a pas des gens enfin
mais voilà troisième quartier concerné
plus en centre-ville Blanqui de passage
dans le quartier cette jeune femme n'est
pas non plus convaincu par l'idée d'une
extinction des lumières la nuit c'est
vrai que c'est pas c'est pas forcément
super sécurisant de rentrer quand il
fait tout noir
quant à cette riveraine elle se demande
pourquoi son quartier a été choisi alors
que de nombreux piétons transitent entre
Saint-Pierre et Tours par le quartier on
a un quartier sympa mais résidentiel non
on n'est pas le quartier Mirabeau on est
le quartier blanc qui
pourquoi notre quartier nous pourquoi
pas venir avant pourquoi pas les
prébendes l'expérimentation va durer 6
mois et d'ici trois mois un
questionnaire sera mise en ligne par la
mairie pour faire le point avec les
habitants des trois quartiers concernés